we'll be careful baby Bobo
baby bellboy
my own friend my best friend in the
whole world
peepee poo-poo fever he betrayed me oh
my god
paper pop oh I'll get you for this I'll
get you for this one Dame he pushed me
in surely it must have been a mistake
there's no way people would deliberately
betray me Oh God I don't have the
material to get to the island
I do have an ender pearl oh I hope this
works
oh oh okay oh I think I pissed one off
hey oh I pissed the dragon off sorry I'm
good if you get to know me oh god I'll
just stare in the corner oh god this is
too scary shield my Swedish in sorry for
this
don't forget they're mine fine is fine
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid
can I mind these okay
Oh God
oh my god he shoot ball ah he should bow
he crazy he should fall at me we're
gonna have to do this the old Swedish
way ah he keeps shooting balls
I'm digging a hole no one can hurt me in
my hole no one is there way out of the
Ender sir way out of this area ha ha
you're approaching me
that's right enderdragon I'm approaching
you because I can't kick your face in
without doing it why there's so many of
you guys
so this is it huh I know a little bit
about O'Connor listen we weren't even
stalking two of them fine pay an elder
penalty arrows can't hurt him I keep
telling you guys no one believed me so
there's these things on top that I have
to shoot higher am I out of arrows oh
god oh god oh god what have I done
Oh God take the eyes it's for my face
this is fine peepee poo-poo once I see
your stupid face you're gonna get a
knuckle sandwich when did this disappear
oh god I only have my Trident oh my god
oh god
stupid ender dragon ah cheap of that
parlor all right I gotta hit the I gotta
hit the things on top got one yeah easy
my aim is 2020
Oh God Oh God which one got pissed up
all right maybe I pissed up a lot of
them for no reason
Oh God by the power of what their sheep
yeah shame gave me strength oh I hit him
damn idiot yeah yeah too strong and
they're dragging more like no problem
man I have to return I have to return
retreat
I do have the enderchest
whoa I have bench I have pumpkin I
already prepared Oh
but with infinity I forgot I did this
and I named it IKEA Bernero there it's
real battle begins now I was ready to
give up oh I think not go boy my army my
army oh he died already just don't ah
sorry bro IKEA bird give me strength
yes I can burn yeah I guess I can see
which one's a healing cuz he's flying
across that one's still healing what
else that one still has it okay
come on yeah did I do it
it's a weird bow-bow okay
if we place water at the bottom and at
least if I fall down I won't dad god
god I'm actually scared it's an iron
gate I did it I did it ha ha this is
going swimmingly
come on army this one is still healing
him dang it oh this is a tough one
I don't understand that I get it I think
I did must have
you only have one power of defense left
coward Oh
oh this is bad Oh what I didn't even do
anything
yes yes yeah come on come on come on
this is for Jurgen to what excuse me
why oh okay
cannonball let's set up the army it's
time to interface to my army
okay here we go here we go here we go
face - keep shooting him yes get on boys
yeah it's working
denim boys whoa keep shooting come down
you coward
this is four okay
wait what is happening I told you he's
immune to arrows I told you guys
Oh boys Oh No now what does she
this is for Rob
this is for this is for I can't bird
well hit him with a pen whoa
Oh God no I didn't know he could do that
space oh hey uh huh don't look at me
sled I'm a failure
oh no hug me guys I need a I'm going to
get my stuff back never run this fast in
my life I'm going to get my stuff yeah I
trusted you and you betrayed me and for
this okay yeah I'm gonna push you in
come here hey I'm gonna push you in so
hard now you don't even know what
pushing means come here come here little
scoundrel oh don't fall up don't be
afraid come on go in yeah
so you listen for oh god quick what are
you afraid little pig
Oh God cuz I am my stuff and he master
oh my god their keep fighting the battle
continues where is my son I see my
pickaxe oh here they are whoa I can't
believe I actually made it oh I'm
digging a hole oh my god my power of
what the Sheep is so soft I got
something to do first there's something
I need to prepare
oh he healed fully are you kidding me
yeah yeah oh God
don't go in there peepee poo-poo no he
died
baby papa happy people beware oh my God
he's a life people you made it oh that
sucks
I just really sucks
[Music]
your name is Fifi poo that's right spam
baby we're gonna beat the ender dragon
together
[Music]
yeah
and we'll need votes this time
I will come prepared I will need my
shield
for the Swedish
it's time
[Music]
take a pork chop and eat it get in the
boat get in the boat
get in the boat hey you get in the hole
hey you get in the boat
get in the boat you will all be in boats
get in the boat
get in
we're all gonna flow get um yeah
oh no wait you're not supposed to be in
the boat no get in the buff
get him in the boat our battle begins
can't hit him I hit him for a second oh
no oh oh god he's hard a hit
yes
time to go to sleep your night gamers
yeah
Oh God in the beginning we died from
sleeping that we used to this
oh god oh god oh god oh that was close
one more time
yes oh my god so close for a cambered
yeah
oh sweet XP Oh what
[Music]
we didn't read a 69 oh man please tell
me I was recruiting friends become
enemies enemies become friends
amazing what a battle
is this the way back where's the egg oh
they're saying so how do I get the egg
again use a torch I think apparently I
need a piston so I'll get it later I'll
get it later gamers I went through we
did it we did it gamers
[Music]
because no one likes you and this is how
this one is like talking to you yet
oh sweet out Smith so I spy friend
Spencer early bait yeah oh yeah we did
it
but we lost a lot of friends on the way
[Music]
but the only fun
come on guys all right you guys ready
for this you're you can't wait oh my god
I can't our forever
I can't ours never been so beautiful
yeah that's beautiful thank you everyone
thank you everyone for watching this
minecraft series it's been an epic
journey with so many memorable moments
so many amazing times I love playing
this for you guys and I hope you guys
have fun as well so therefore we're
gonna end it
brofist psych
you really thought it was over huh
there's so many things more in Minecraft
that's right Smith I can't leave you
behind I have to get the alight try so I
can fly in stuff I see you gamers in the
next episode
you